to answer this question we have to go to
the marshlands of Ireland here there's a
phenomenon called ignis fatis more
commonly called will of the Wisps will
the Wisps are ghost lights seen Atop The
Waters of swamps and this phenomenon
bore many ghost stories one of which is
the tale of Stingy Jack so Stingy Jack
was an unsavory fellow who had a
fondness for mischief and booze dozens
of versions of the story exist but in
each version Jack tricks the devil to
ice over in doing so he convinces the
devil to not take his soul when he dies
so when Jack did eventually die he found
himself barred from hell and from heaven
so Jack was cursed to wander in the
darkness forever with just a lantern
made from a turnip to light his way
these turnip lanterns often carved with
a scary face were quite common in
Ireland and Scotland used as a way of
keeping Stingy Jack as well as other
mischievous Spirits away in the 19th
century the influx of Irish immigrants
the U.S bringing their tradition with
them and they found the pumpkin to be a
good substitute for their turnips